luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and today i am going to be doing
some survival camping
here in alaska
how can you say no to that okay luke and
jake here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and today we're going survival
camping here in alaska
wait wait do you guys want to go camping
too yeah okay
you guys can come along luke tom nate
and jake here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and today we're going
survival camp i want to go
to okay you can come too becca all right
luke tom nate jake and becca here with
the outdoor boys me too but
can we not do the survival part okay you
can sleep in your car
fine luke tom nate jake rebecca and my
sister melanie here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel and today we're
going camping and some of us are going
survival camping
in the wilderness of alaska
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is kenai lake here
almost down
[Music]
i think if i hop on that see-saw you're
gonna die you want me to do it all right
maybe like almost dies every time we hit
the ground
should we make a bridge
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
sorry
well there we go hey guys
all right guys you want to go across
all right guys shall we explore yeah
come on i need to find a spot to camp
well we've got lots of firewood lots of
building material
i think this looks like a good place to
build our shelter
look at this an old door hinge
it's the heel to a boot that looks like
a bit of a saw
come on boys we're gonna do a little
camping here and my wife and sister are
going to be joining us which is a
special treat
so i reserved some sights for them so
we're going to go ahead and get the
campsite set up and get the boys fed
and when they show up then we are going
to go down the shores of the lake
and do some survival camping
start gathering up firewood and put it
in the back of the car
see this see these chunks and this is
cottonwood bark
these burn really good
that's my my boss man
all right we got these diamond willows
here we need to find a willow switch for
hot dogs here
oh there's a there's one
i've got some ketchup and i've got hot
dogs
there you go
there you go eat that up buddy
well we got a late lunch out of the way
now i got to start making dinner
got something special here
oh
[Music]
that fire is kind of smoky i think i
need to fan it a little bit
it's a truck
oh my goodness there's a nathan up there
you're gonna be so covered in pine tar
i've discovered over the years that
diapers and pull-ups make excellent hot
pads
all right that looks perfect that looks
absolutely perfect
[Laughter]
[Music]
those tears are real people
a nice tent spawn here
where are our children we're gonna show
you a little bit of a diversity
of approaches to camping here so i'm
gonna try to go do the survival stuff
becca's gonna sleep in a tent with a cot
and my sister melanie is making an art
form out of car
camping so you've got a kia soul here
which is
i think a compact car both seats need to
go all the way forward and lean all the
way forward
you got these boxes these storage boxes
and you just flip them upside down
stick them in the wheel well yeah once i
put my weight on it
it's pretty flush
hi jacob my sister's six foot two and
she can sleep
stretched out in the back of a kia soul
with his system so
a couple boxes go a long way you got a
little faux mat there oh absolutely
gonna
if you're gonna go all out you need to
go all out you got an air mattress on
top of your foam
absolutely so you just barely under
inflate a full-size air mattress and it
fits
just right well check it out she's got
this mosquito netting that goes over the
doors
so you can roll the windows down keep
the bugs out got a nice little
lamp here nice plenty of room to sit
a little pouch for her stuff well it is
pretty slick
this is pretty slick it is really
comfortable go for it
no he's
[Music]
quarter this thing up
[Music]
all righty all right guys who wants some
chicken
put your plate there's your plate
did you like the chicken i liked it so
much it is gone
well it's time for dessert and i brought
marshmallows but my sister
also brought marshmallows which one do
you want
i want the big one with a big lemon
cookie what do you guys got for dessert
hershey's i also brought lemon cookies
look at the difference in those one's a
small planet and the other one's a
marshmallow
did you just eat that entire chocolate
bar but i'm making it smooth
here's here's a lemon cookie for you i
think i'm about to extract
it
yeah you like that bacon is that good
that's really good and look at this
it's gooey inside is that your lemon
cookie s'more
it is looks good doesn't it
yes it's something
well guys we got about an hour before
bedtime and i'm gonna go see if we can
pick some watermelon berries uh before
bedtime
oh you find some tom that one oh that
one's right definitely
definitely ripe no not many
plant another berry bush oh my goodness
it's pretty sparse pickings look right
there see that bush oh that's huge
that's the right one and it's a big one
well there's a bunch of them on there
it's a jackpot for real
there's a watermelon berry plant right
there see if there's any
we would not survive off of our foraging
skills today
we got maybe 10 12. i'll miss you
i love you baby got some of this shelf
life milk
lasts a couple months without
refrigeration until you open it at least
there we go got some milk for jacob well
it's getting late and me and jacob are
gonna head off and go build our survival
shelter now poor jacob has
always wanted to come on these campouts
and so very rarely gets to come so this
is one where i think i can bring him
pretty easily so
jacob and me are gonna go out camping
you excited buddy
yeah yeah i got one now
all right jake you ready follow me
all right buddy you ready to cross the
bridge all right let's see if we can do
it
oh yes the water's gotten deeper there
we made it
oh you found you found a fishing bobber
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what do you think should we camp here
yep
one bad thing about sleeping on beaches
bears love to prowl up and down beaches
especially at night so we're gonna keep
the bear maze handy
first thing we do is we measure
our the space we need
inflate the air mattress first so i know
what size to make the shelter
that's my template
look
um
you like the 10 yeah
[Applause]
i think we got room you got a little
shelter built jake seems to be digging
it time to get into your jammies
well tonight we're gonna try out a new
sleeping quilt i got the boys it just
arrived in the mail
i think enlightened equipment makes this
thing um but it's
really soft and it's super light and uh
we're gonna see if jacob likes it
okay got these adhesive hand warmers
here we're gonna slap those
there you go yeah you look cozy
there's tickle holes in here
jacob are you having fun yeah you are
full of energy
how many how many marshmallows did you
eat you ate a ton of marshmallows
[Music]
it's bedtime
oh
[Music]
well gosh darn jacob did pretty good
last night he woke up around two
complaining about something and i
i think it was the adhesive warmer on
his back got a little too hot so i took
that off and snuggled him up
and and he seemed to do really well
after that but it's kind of cold it's
about 40 degrees right now that
that fire feels really good what a
beautiful morning
i wake up in my sleeping bag and open my
eyes
and i see this i can hear loons calling
occasional trout jumping right off there
got a roaring fire going to keep the
cold away
man this is nice this is really nice
i'm just going to sit and take this in
for a bit
so
so
i've got some steel cut oatmeal here
this is the good stuff
[Applause]
if you're not a fan of oatmeal it's
probably because you're eating instant
oatmeal
try real steel cut oatmeal you'll never
go back
now i could be cooking this by just
laying it straight on the coals
but when you want to simmer something
and adjust the temperature a little more
something like this works pretty darn
well
well there's something substantial
making noise in the woods behind me
just uh keep that close
now the squirrels are going bonkers and
now the squirrels are making their
little warning chatter
they don't do that for moose normally
i'm not too worried about the bears that
can see us
it's the bears that get surprised that
scare me i can hear sticks snapping
pretty big ones over there now it's
moving over there
there we go an ugly little spoon
all right nice dab of butter
hey jake
i got a fire over there you want to warm
up by the fire
come on out of the tent and i'll get you
some food okay
i got some oatmeal for you well he's not
coming out gotta go in after him
hi jake sit down
that's nice and warm isn't it
oh you like that
did you get your spoon dirty yeah you
want me to wash it
yes oh [ __ ] let me see your spoon i'll
go watch it
there you go you want to go see mama now
all right let's pack up put the fire out
and go see mama okay
all right jacob let's go get mama
should we cross the bridge
yeah that was close
oh you came back
good morning melody
all right guys did you have fun
well hopefully you guys enjoyed watching
this video as much as we enjoyed making
it if you want to see more videos from
the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every saturday morning
and check the link below for lists of
other videos which you might like
including our six week tour of alaska
thanks for watching guys if you liked
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching